[Music]
oh
we're gonna make your morning easy buddy
companies like green diamonds
you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
that's the most i've ever heard lorraine
speak that's the most i've ever heard
lorraine speak
[Music]
this is elle my assistant
we're making the whitaker's breakfast um
do you have milk
no i don't know no milk okay that's okay
we'll have healthy eggs
gummy meal
milk
or cream
no okay that's okay i got butter milk
um that could work yeah
i can't eat milk
what's that i can't eat milk for rain
rain ray drinks all the milk
[Music]
a lot of
these things individuals
buying offsets for their plane trip how
do they know that any of that is that
you are you watch a lot of tv
there's no regulations that exist in the
usage of these credits so a lot of this
might just be making people feel that
some of it certainly is
he also worries some companies are now
being paid to do what they would have
done anyway
let their trees grow
the discussion looks a lot like an
offset
[Music]
no
[Laughter]
microsoft
including this one we visited last year
in iceland this is going to make history
yes
which actually sucks carbon dioxide out
of the air
thank you you got it
everybody okay
[Music]
what
nothing
[Music]
disagrees with that characterization in
the span of about less than 10 years
we've essentially burned through the
insurance protections that were like the
last 100.
i think it's right baby
douglas reed acknowledges the offsets
market may need higher standards that
says trees are worth the risk it's
beautiful here in the morning
that's
[Music]
is
you get a break today
oh look at that right
[Music]
he
anyway
right is it good
do you like it
yeah okay cool okay
[Applause]
you're selling horses
you two figured to make ten dollars
ahead
are you calling us thieves
mr parker yes that's a pretty accurate
description
is it good lauren
who does the dishes around here
who does the dishes around here
colonel thomas is a factor
i i do the teaching and he does it
sometimes
i'm going to do them yeah timmy's very
helpful isn't it
can you watch
he'll harder working no more
i'm gonna get on again
i am
you gotta train these boys
i watched them this morning
i did
let's understand each other
one of the bravest warriors that ever
wrote a heart
and on top of that he's my adopted son
uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
you like it right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dogs water dogs want some too either
you don't want to wait right there
are you
[Music]
[Music]
it's about time betty got a break right
[Music]
i like that timmy
timmy's clever
he made a sandwich out of it
you like john wayne
i can just feel all that money in my
pocket right now
hey
what are you going to do with it when
you get it
well i had to give that a lot of good
books
set right down on the notion
gonna buy me some pack animals and trap
whatever's left over i'm gonna get drunk
and if i ever sober up again i'm heading
for the rocky
go to st louis and open up a little cat
house
were they quiet out there would you
believe it john henry i had to wait to
the men
let's hope it stays that way
you ain't expecting drugs
americans in mexico taking academy of
horses to a very unpopular government
why should we expect trouble
how come you didn't tell us that
great job
it's dessert this is dessert pancakes
can we take some of these out sure
yeah
henry
who wants pancakes
do you want a pancake
no do you want a pancake
just down the
[Music]
[Music]
i don't believe it
[Music]
[Music]
i ran out of plates so it's a pancake in
a bowl
let me get you a fork
[Music]
right
[Music]
i'll hold it for you
if you liked it i don't know if it was
ah is it good do you like okay cool cool
i will come cook for you whenever you're
good
i'll come cook your squash in the garden
riders moving
[Music]
you look good for six years yeah i don't
everybody tell me i do yeah yeah you're
healthy
what health ailments do you have
what what health problems do you have or
yeah hard work
yeah you're set
[Music]
yeah you're right oh
it's from the puppy
women
thomas
yes captain i was
excellent
oh i thought you were younger
yeah wow
[Music]
so you're 70. larry's 66.
how old is ray
ray
28
[Music]
[Music]
next month
were you by chance and chicken lover i
asked because i lost my brother there
hann's husband
i lost 23 in my house and kenneth you're
old you're young
no how old are you you're 65.
now your parents were
putting out kids every every year
i guess you have to when you have 14
14
there are 14 children
sixteen kids so you gotta you gotta get
busy if you're gonna have 16 kids
i know
16 kids
oh
you ever been on an airplane timmy have
you been have you ever been out of west
virginia
no
never
where where have you been we've been
whenever
where
virginia
your family is originally from virginia
right yeah
your parents are from virginia
next to white gays
[Music]
i can't think of it
i want my dad to be right
it's in virginia or west virginia
what
well that was beautiful
hairspray
yeah
tell me about your parents what were
they like
really nice
what was your dad like
what my dad liked what was your dad like
well it could be me
he can't
he wasn't my ass by any time really yeah
when i've done something wrong like what
yeah you're getting in trouble yeah
yeah
he's a coal miner yeah he was coat
mining
he walked
away
every day and
and people giving around every night
coming home
everything and
and
until he got hurt
[Music]
betty was your mom like
mommy is that boring
she was rough on you guys yeah
in what ways
oh
so
did you ever have a boyfriend i had a
boyfriend i was in school yeah
do you wish you'd gotten married
do you wish you had gotten married
i had to be married
you've been married before oh never
i think i have you've been married i
haven't stay home take care of my
brothers and sisters so who
so timmy is
lorraine's son yeah and who is timmy's
father
my mother was a scientist at starglass
and she was obsessed
you never knew
she was right
oh she was raped
how old was she when she had
how old was she when this happened
how'd you go lay down
has ray ever had a girlfriend no
you ever had a girlfriend ray hey
yeah he says yes
[Music]
oh yeah i got that
ray you ever had a girlfriend hey hey
tell me tell me about her
hey
what do you know kenneth
what what do you know about rey and
women
i didn't know he had what i
had holding on
you know what
he ain't
and i got you all he she does
ring
when ray had hope
but he like just
aggressively took her or what yeah
again she wasn't cooperating
cause gray hat hold over
that's what we were told
we don't know
i have no idea what i was talking about
that was a long time ago yeah yeah
that was a long time ago
he was tell me about freddie
freddie was about the same age as uh ray
right no greg
freddie hold on hold your face he was
yeah
what did he stand easy
yeah
right hoe afraid he was hold on
oh
yeah freddie was older yeah oh is that
right he's older than you huh he was
older than you yeah wow he looked good
yeah freddy was uh
i
can't quite
remember how he was and he was the
oldest boy here
he was
his personality was was mellower than
race
ray used to get very
anxious and angry and yeah crazy yeah
he's ray has mellowed a lot brady was
calm down
and you can understand freddie a whole
lot better you can ray
you can you could i don't i don't
remember freddie speaking much either
i don't remember freddie speaking much
he didn't talk much no freedom to talk
about he does one
to me and
everybody else he's kind of like
lorraine yeah yeah he was quiet
now he
they might not
can't talk
but if you're working on anything
if you need a wrench
you tell what side wrench you want
they go get it they bring
the right side wrench you need
would you say ray and uh
freddy
and maybe even lorraine and timmy are
they're smarter than they
appear right they're just not sp they're
not verbal they're smart you know they
can't speak
talk
have you seen have you seen doctors
about that
mom dad did you know yeah where the
doctors find out
yeah
what you're yep
you know
my dog
all patrol you know
and they never didn't mention nothing
else about it
but then
you know
i guess i really understand what you're
saying yeah i know ray and i communicate
yeah very well i think
they like i said they might think
they understand what you talking about
be good
what do you mean
well they understand what you're
talking about if they don't like it they
they start yelling like you know
they get frustrated that
you don't understand them or yeah yeah
oh jimmy
timmy what's going on with you what's
going on in your world how's your summer
been
yeah how's your summer been
how your summer been tammy
how many have you summoned me
huh
you don't you don't see many
you don't see many families that sit
around
together
like this yeah you guys are always
together
and you're and you're always happy
yeah
find me another family that hangs out
like this
not too bad not too many
hey dog
you guys ever go for a walk down the
street down the road
can we walk out yeah
we walk around yards and garden
everything and
who's in charge of the garden you betty
who who grows everything in your garden
we don't
do it
you want to show me what you're growing
you want to show me what you're growing
in the garden
[Applause]
right here
that's all it hurts
tomatoes you haven't made it
down
right there
you wanna show me what's on the road
take me for a walk
[Applause]
yeah you got a satellite dish
[Music]
uh
what do you do for fun right the day
what do you do for fun here
[Applause]
is that right you already
ah you like it
yeah
what's that mean
timmy was lorraine a good mom
was your was lorraine a good mom to you
do you love your mom
and now he's gold and he drinks about 34
bottles
oh that's all right
that's a lot of soda what's
[Music]
[Music]
nobody's shaving
no one's shaving here
show me what you're getting here where
are you growing ready
squash
nice
you grow those here
yeah going right out there right all
right your garden's beautiful
he has a job working it too
you still do the
[Music]
thank you wow thank you so much
[Music]
what's ray's favorite show
[Music]
give them some love look how happy they
are
so the bible says now 38 years 38 years
they come past this mountain 38 years
yeah ready
[Music]
you're right
[Music]
race norse
to your own self
the same thing
expecting
i want somebody
a different different result a different
outcome you do the same thing but you
expect different results that's the
definition of insanity
men that get involved
[Music]
but you got to make up your mind i'm in
this thing so here i am so linda and i
first girl ever gets behind the church
graduation she was an older woman
i was 14 she was 16.
yeah
so you know man
oh it's fully stocked
you guys are all set
what do you like for dinner what's your
favorite thing to eat
oh yeah
that's where you guys take it back
no shower just a bath
i'm glad we were able to feed you huh
i'm glad we were able to feed you before
work
we'll see you next time
oh
[Music]
oh my god thank you what is that squash
yeah
[Laughter]
thank you thank you so much
you